today's question comes from Kristen in
Florida Dave took out a lease on a
vehicle about four months ago before
enrolling in Financial Peace University
I feel like I've made one of the worst
mistakes in my life you have I was
wondering if you could give me some
advice on how it would affect me if I
were to return the leased car to the
dealership or at this point do I just
keep the vehicle none of the above we
take a car back that you owe money on or
I've signed the lease on that's
effectively a voluntary repossession and
that that would be dumped because
they're going to sell the car after
they've repossessed it and they're you
know a repossession lot and then they're
going to sue you for the difference if
you don't pay them the difference
immediately and you don't have the
difference because you're broke so no
that would be a dumb idea we're not
going to do that what we are going to do
is find out two pieces of information
one is call the car fleece company that
you are paying the fleece to yes you're
being fleeced and find out what the
early buyout on the car is now the early
buyout is different than the total of
your lease payments plus your residual
value at the end it should be less
because your this leases are very new
and there should be it's kind of like an
early payoff on the loan it doesn't
include all the interest from the time
that you know from keeping the loan the
whole time so the early buyout is your
early payoff now that what it's what's
taking play the car off they can get the
title in your hand then you compare that
to kbb.com Kelly Blue Book com private
sale what the car is actually worth and
I'll just make up some numbers let's
pretend that the early buyout is twenty
thousand and then you look it up and the
car is actually worth sixteen thousand
that would leave you four thousand
dollars in the hole it's probably not
far off of what you're gonna find
so four thousand dollars in the hole
means you sell the car
416 you've got to put $4,000 cash with
the 16 in order to get the title for the
buyer and so you have to have that other
$4,000 you have to be able to cover the
hole that you're in the amount that you
are upside down in the way you would do
that is obviously a loan and so you
start working with your local credit
union with your local bank and you get a
loan lined up for the amount that you're
upside down you put the car up for sale
and you sell the car for as much as you
can possibly get for it which is more
than they will sell it for on the repo a
lot see the bottom line is you're gonna
be responsible for this difference
either way but the difference is greater
and you do more damage to your life and
lose more control of your life by doing
a repossession and so you cover the
difference cover the amount that you're
upside down with another loan and I'd
rather you be $4,000 in debt than
$24,000 in debt or whatever the numbers
are so they remember telling you to
borrow money no Dave Ramsey's telling
you to move some of the debt and get rid
of the majority of the debt by doing
that and so you borrow and cover the
amount that you're upside down